another brutal day of cold in Chicago as
the city tries to grind back into action
they even sent an icebreaker down the
Chicago River and it's already started
to freeze back over and although it
hasn't quite broken the records here it
was the coldest it's been in Chicago
since 1985 for those who ventured
outside it's been challenging horrible I
can't believe that I'm out here but I am
because I have to go to work and I'm
responsible I don't know and that's what
I'm supposed to do but it's super cold
and as you can see I'm still trying to
catch my breath it's awful
I'm headed to Florida on Saturday
because of it you were escaping I'm
escaping yeah is it that bad it's
terrible I can't wait for it to be over
it's Chicago in January I know to expect
it but spring can't come soon enough the
polar vortex cold air rushing south from
the Arctic has meant plenty of
interesting experiments wet shirts
frozen solid in minutes
step aboard the frozen frozen bubbles
and boiling water turning to snow in
midair
despite the fun these conditions are
dangerous and have already been blamed
for a number of deaths in New Jersey
firefighters struggled against the
elements to contain a blaze at this
paper mill the main ingredient there is
the wind and that just plain and you
know feeds a flame and feeds a fire and
causes it to spread rapidly Travel it's
still treacherous especially on frozen
roads and for those without heat at home
it's potentially life-threatening
hispano ice at 3:30 in the morning and
it was a recording in the gas company
just basically saying that we have no
heat and no hot water and it's stressful
and they're crying because they're
scared so we just let him wake up
naturally and then
as soon as he woke up we got out of
there now this deadly weather event is
pushing East bringing more misery to
millions in the Midwest temperatures are
expected to recover by the weekend and
relief can't come soon enough
Hanna Thomas Peter Sky News in Chicago